what's up guys and welcome to hobbies
the channel where we discussed the
latest tech news and dog went to newest
tech products today we're taking a look
at why you shouldn't buy a used GPU
despite it being used for mining or not
but before we begin then make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
would like to be updated with the latest
tech news related to PCs and gaming also
if you guys are interested and why
aetherium is officially dead
then make sure it is check out my
dedicated video on that but anyways the
reason you guys shouldn't wait is that
the next series of GPUs is actually
coming out very soon I know that Nvidia
didn't tell us anything about the next
series at GDC
but gamer nexus was actually able to get
in contact with SK Hynix who is actually
the producer for memory for Nvidia
graphics cards and they told a gamer
Nexus that they are starting their mass
production for GT dr6 memory in just
three months and since this is a ram
company for nvidia i do believe that
this is telling us that the next series
of GPUs from Nvidia is coming out very
soon also next generation should have
great performance NVIDIA hasn't really
showed us anything about the next series
but considering what they can do like
with the Volt to be 100 and other crazy
high level cards we know that they have
a lot of performance available to give
us they're obviously not going to give
us all de but I do believe that they're
going to match last generational gaps
like for example the 980 was equal to
ten sixty so this generation I do
believe is a 1080 will be equal with
eleven sixty and so on and so forth so
the performance looks great and it's
definitely a significant upgrade from
what we have right now so if you guys
have the money to buy a used car right
now you guys can probably afford a mid
to your card in the next series so I
really recommend it you guys wait for
that because it will provide you with
much superior performance and plus it'll
be a new graphics card instead of a used
one so the performance is great and all
but when exactly is it coming y'all
they're starting their production and I
would say July and so I would think that
the 1170 and 1180 will probably come out
at the end of summer and 1150 and 1160
will probably come out at the end of
this year and
there's like the 1150 TI and 1180 TI
will come out sometime next year the
only downfall about these new graphics
cards is that they're going to be a bit
more expensive but honestly the used car
that you are considering to buy right
now or probably overpriced tuned and by
the time that these new graphics cards
come out
I believe that GPU should have
stabilized in price and so it's probably
what you're spending right now so the
same price that you're spending right
now let's say to get it 10 60 I bet you
guys can snatch 1160 a few months from
now and if you guys wait for holiday
season then you'll probably even get a
better view well what if you're like I
don't care about new GPUs or the little
extra performance that I can get from
them well even current generation GPUs
or on a downfall right now because
there's much less demand coming from
minors the price of cryptocurrencies are
taking a huge hit and difficulty to mine
them is constantly going up and as a
result there's much less demand from
minors for graphics cars and thoughts
the price are going down there are also
new a6 being introduced to mind specific
cryptocurrencies like aetherium and even
the developers of these cryptocurrencies
are worried about their future and are
considering to implement a hard fork so
as you guys can see it's a really bad
time for GPU miners and as a result
that's why they're selling their
graphics cards and because of that GPU
prices for current generation cards are
going to go down very soon and I've
already been going down and they're
gonna continue to go down for a few
months and the only thing that's going
to hold them back from hitting MSRP is
going to be RAM prices so if you guys
weigh a little bit more you can get the
same car that you're getting right now
new instead of used you maybe even for a
cheaper price also why would you even
consider buying a used GPU it really
doesn't make that much sense because
you've been waiting for so long anyway
so you might ask well with it's just a
little bit more and get a new GPU for
the same price also you don't really
know what happened to GPU even if it
really wasn't used for mining it could
have other issues like first Haul
lifespan
the previous owner could have kept or
revolted or overused or at high
temperatures all the time and all of
those who could degrade the lifetime of
the GPU and as a result generally have
any certainty of how long it's going to
last so I really don't recommend you
guys buy I use GPU right now it's a
really bad time for miners and so mines
are trying to recoup their costs by
selling their GPUs and as a result a lot
of them are probably lying to you and
telling you that their GPUs were not
used for mining even though they really
work so don't be mislead by those miners
need to be able to sell their cards out
before the price drop comes because they
probably bought the GPU overpriced
anyways so if they sold it for less than
real MSRP they'll be losing a lot of
money and so they want to sell it out as
soon as possible so that it probably
would lie about its situation so please
just don't get scammed by those by just
completely avoiding the situation
altogether but just wait a little bit
longer and buying a new GPU when they
drop in price in the imminent future so
here's the gist of what happened in
theory M which is one of the most
prominent cryptocurrencies to be mined
with GPUs is not doing so well and
there's also better alternatives coming
out very soon and as a result GPU miners
are flooding them a third party used
market and Amazon and eBay to be able to
sell their GPUs and recoup their
investments before it's too late and as
a result there's a lot of GPUs out on
the market right now even being offered
for good deals I guess but you guys
shouldn't buy them no matter how good of
a deal it is because you don't know what
it's been through and this miners or
whoever is selling it to you couldn't be
lying to you about its condition also
why would you want to buy a used GPU
after you've been waiting so long to buy
a good GPU that you want and do you
really want miners to recoup their costs
or the root cause that you were getting
screwed for so long make sure think
about that before you purchase that used
GPU but that's pretty much all I have
for you guys this time make sure to
comment down below what you
think about this for example what do you
think are going to happen with all the
mine GPUs are they gonna be on the
market for a long time or do you think
people are just gonna buy them even
though they've been used for mining make
sure to post you guys think because I do
mean all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video then make sure to drop a like
and subscribe if you would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time
[Music]